Michael Knight is Memorial has seen its
where since his death October 22nd 2011
in the city of Downey California NIDA
was a 31 year old father of four who
worked in construction on the day he
died he was out on a date with his wife
when she stopped to refill the car with
gas night I ran across the street to buy
cigarettes in the same part of town two
officers from the Downey Police
Department were investigating an armed
robbery
they approached and then detained NIDA
NIDA had nothing to do with the robbery
but grew up in South Los Angeles and had
a fear of law enforcement so after being
detained he ran from police he was
detained again shortly thereafter but
managed to escape a second time the last
time he got away sheriff officials said
that he stopped and turned around in an
aggressive manner the moment before he
turned around officer Steve Gilley fired
at night out with his gun striking him
twice in the back from 20 feet away
officers found out later that Nyjah was
unarmed night Asgardians ever since he
was a baby or Jean and Jerry Thaxton and
both refer to night as their son so when
they received a call about the shooting
they rushed the scene we were there when
they put him in the ambulance we knew he
didn't have much of a chance NIDA died
at the hospital of multiple gunshot
wounds his story may sound like a police
misconduct story you've heard before a
man was mistakenly shot unarmed and
later died except for a curious detail I
know wasn't shot with a handgun he was
shot with an mp5 submachine gun the same
gun used by the Navy SEALs why would
they have a machine gun we're not in a
war zone I didn't think I didn't think
this was a war zone why were the police
with this military type weapon it
doesn't seem to be a good answer for
that
Timothy Lynch is the director of the
project on criminal justice at the Cato
Institute he has cautioned for years
about the militarization of local police
departments your ordinary patrolman is
not going to be have on his person a
submachine gun even if they have those
types of weapons they should only be
called out in extraordinary and rare
circumstances such as when they know
that they're going to be confronting
a barricaded suspect there were a group
of suspects that they know are going to
be heavily armed Lynch says police have
been arming themselves for decades a lot
of people think the militarization of
our police departments began with 9/11
it actually started well before then in
the times where Congress wanted to ramp
up the drug war today's headlines make
clear that the war on drugs that
President Nixon declared in 1973 is
still being waged and that it's special
agents over 2,200 of them are on the
frontlines they began to make this type
of equipment available to civilian
police departments m16s grenade
launchers these armored personnel
carriers and the mp5 but it doesn't
matter what the weapon is when police
have equipment they want to use it at
first when they got it the idea was okay
well yeah this is extraordinary weaponry
we'll have it just in case we ever need
it but then as it crept along the
rationale became look we've got this
weaponry these tactics we've been doing
this military-type training let's put it
to use let's use them to execute drug
warrants first it was just our major
metropolitan areas that would have a
SWAT unit the SWAT teams are no longer
just in the big cities they're in mid
size and even small towns now and then
suddenly they're just carrying these
things in their police cars and more
routine calls the Downey Police
Department did not want to speak on
camera but told us that they acquired
the mp5s during the mid-90s that being
said it's actually hard to pin down
where police departments get machineguns
and submachine guns
sometimes they outright buy them
sometimes the money is acquired through
asset forfeiture but sometimes they get
them from someplace else they're getting
them from the Pentagon from time to time
the Pentagon makes surplus military
equipment available to the local Police
Department sometimes they're practically
just giving it away just for the
departments that will apply for it they
apply for it through the Pentagon's 1033
program a program that for 17 years has
supplied local police with millions of
dollars worth of military-grade
equipment at bottom dollar prices does
your Police Department needle
large sport utility vehicle they've got
that how about an airplane or even a
helicopter they've got those too in fact
the program grew so popular that had to
be put on hold recently when police
chiefs began transferring equipment
received elsewhere we've had some
reports of police chiefs initially
getting equipment but then maybe two
years later they are selling it to
somebody else
but it doesn't stop there politicians
have even made it easier for local
police to militarize under this program
Congress feat years ago created like a
1-800 number where the local police
departments can call find out what's
available get the application process
started
Lynch is also quick to point out that
just because police have equipment
doesn't mean they know how to use it
they've gotten their hands on the
military equipment then it gets to the
question of training and sometimes
they're not trained to use the weapons
in an appropriate fashion and sometimes
that training comes alongside members of
the military something Lynch says is
troubling because although they may look
the same their roles are very different
they both carry weapons they both wear
uniforms but that's where the
similarities end military's mission is
to find the enemy and inflict heavy
damage on them they're not thinking
about constitutional rights the civilian
police are encountering people in the
community people who do have
constitutional rights and their job is
to use the absolute minimum amount of
force so when you have these two units
training alongside one another it's
bringing the wrong type of tactics into
our communities it's totally
inappropriate versus free society it's
not just about the weapons in the
officers hands it's about the
militarization mentality local police
officers bring to their jobs our son was
shot in the back he was murdered
kidding have a weapon he wasn't involved
in a crime he wasn't on probation of
parole he was a gang member and he
wasn't safe he wasn't safe from the
people that's supposed to be protecting
him every Saturday the Thaksin's rally
with family members and friends at the
sight of knidos death and they're
looking after their grandkids even more
now he was a
man that shouldn't happen he was my baby
when he didn't feel good he always came
to me officer Gilley who fired the mp5
was put on leave but his back now on the
force temporarily reassigned to the
administrative division of the Downey
Police Department I think he needs to
make peace with his god but I really do
hope that he goes to prison for this for
killing her son